well first of all the song is super dope
i'm actually so excited
all the lyrics you can use as captions
for your instagram posts
okay that's what people love and it's
just a vibe it's kind of like
i just really love it and i'm excited
for it to come out so first of all
how did this collaboration happen who
approached who
was it a text was it a dm was it a
pull-up
was it a pull-up um well we wanted to do
this along with kanaji forever we've
been a big fan of
music and her just for for years now so
um
the song came together and we uh we had
we had the idea of it going
we sent it over to her she liked it um
we weren't able to get together in the
studio unfortunately because of
obviously gobed um but uh she did her
thing on her vocals absolutely killed it
and we were able to get together after
the fact for some photos and stuff and
shooting the video really soon too so
yeah well tinashe can record vocals
anywhere it's true
i have a studio in my house though so
it's perfect so i just popped downstairs
and i was able to record most of my
music
in the quarantine at my house so it was
it made perfect sense that i was just
able to get that done write that verse
send it through
yeah bam boom bam bam bam
she killed it yeah tanasha you've been
doing that though like before
quarantine you've been set up to just
record and roll and produce and make
things happen like you've always been
like
self-sufficient in that way yeah i
started making my music in my bedroom at
my
parents house and recording my own music
there so it's always been really nice
for me to have that kind of
home environment and it looks like
trevor are you at home right now because
yeah where are you i'm at home
i'm in my bedroom and literally saying
vibe i have like a studio set up right
here
it's like always trying to be able to do
you know never have to leave if i don't
have to
yeah i feel like it's becoming more and
more of
like the new wave in terms of other
artists especially because of lockdown
everyone kind of got their studio setups
popping but yeah been very advantageous
to always be able to do your own stuff
in your own space oh so valuable
um trevor you've worked with everyone
from demi lovato
liam payne little mix what do you look
for in an artist
ooh i mean for us it's always just been
wanting to like work with artists that
we can like create something different
and sort of like meet in the middle with
what they do
and what we do and create something
different and uh
yeah so being able to work with artists
that like sort of
let us step out of our box has always
been like a big big focus for us so
yeah tenache so when you do get asked to
collaborate with someone
like what's the first thing you consider
is it their vibe
is it their voice the number one thing
i look for is the song if i think the
song is fun
catchy a bop something i want to listen
to i'm like tell me more
and then probably from there i i'll go
and and figure out you know
yeah what's the artist's vibe like what
are what are they saying what are they
about and cheat codes is
pure fun good energy i love all of the
energy that they always have on all
their songs so i was like you know what
going into 2021
that's exactly the type of energy i want
to bring to the world just
positivity and happiness yeah you know
carefree vibe so i thought it was the
perfect collab it is the perfect lap
trevor tell us about this song
give us the t break it down tell the
people what they want
oh man well the concept you know it's
the song's called lean on me and
i think it definitely fits the vibe for
right now and i think it's what people
need to hear especially with like
how hard the last year's been i think
people need a little pick-me-up so
i think this song is definitely that
yeah
so the song's about finding that special
someone so if i ask your close friends
would they say you guys were the type of
people that would catch feelings quickly
after you meet some special someone or
no what would they say are you guys
oh it's interesting for me because
if i meet someone and i like them it's
so rare
that like i'll probably go all in
because 99 of the time i don't i don't
like anyone
i'm super picky like insanely so
what yeah that's me like no one
yeah i'm like no no no
no i totally get that i've definitely
been very very picky in the past um i
think that it's just a matter of like
yeah
it's rare but once in a while you can
definitely i'll definitely you know
dive in if i feel a vibe and think
someone's special
i don't know trevor i feel like you
might be getting caught up in these
streets something
like oh yeah no no i don't know wow i've
been i've been
chilling
who do you guys lean on in your own life
like who is your rock
for me my family's my rock i mean i'm
very very close to my siblings my
parents
um my mom and dad are like the strongest
smartest people i know so
i would definitely say them you know
what i was going to say exactly the same
thing it's always my family
i have a extremely tight-knit family
unit
and they are always there for me and i
just love being able to have that
you know that's sweet um trevor
now this song will appear on your debut
album hellraiser part one
how would you describe the journey that
fans will go through
with this album oh man
uh well it's definitely been like
because it's like a part a three-part
album it's definitely a whole journey
there's a lot of music to go through
um each section is a different vibe like
the first section is very like pop
oriented and sort of represents like
just like me and the music that i've
always loved growing up listening to and
part two is definitely like oriented to
like kevi's kevi's vibe and
sort of like hip-hop emo sort of vibe
and the third section is very um
it's very dance so it's like classic
chico stuff that we've always sort of
put out so
um being able to do something like that
a little bit different than what people
might expect from us
and and being able to give body some
everybody a whole like large body of
work is something we've always wanted to
do
yeah how did we get to three parts you
just making that much music
well there's three of us so i mean i
guess it's sort of fitting and uh
yeah it's something we've always wanted
to do i mean we've been together for
like five or six years and we've never
done
an album actually which is sort of crazy
we've always like done singles and eps
and like just started touring so heavily
like
that we didn't really have the time to
sit down and do a full body of work so
when we sat down during quarantine we
had so much time that we've never really
had before
and uh we started making all these songs
and like we would you know divide and
conquer and do
as many sessions as we could you know
between the three of us and um we came
together and just had like so many
different ideas that we liked and didn't
feel like we wanted to
you know only have to pick one vibe we
feel like we could just like sort of
um separate them into different sections
and be able to let people hear it all
yeah when cheat codes has you know six
billion streams do you feel
pressure when working on projects like
this
uh i don't no never i mean i just enjoy
making music and we're just like super
lucky to be able to do it every day
and to just always try to push the
envelope and make something new and
i try not to think about it too much i
don't want to leave my house and just
make music and
do my thing so yeah tanasha what's the
chances y'all going to collaborate again
on a scale of one to ten i mean the fact
that this is our first collab and it's
already
fire exactly okay that the chances are
high
like i love circling it back like let's
run it back
exactly oh my gosh and i know you worked
with brittany
so i'm just saying maybe there's a
oh maybe there's no maybe we'll all
collab like we'll do that exactly
ultimate collab something i would love
to see
i'm here for it trevor after working
with tinashe
of course damn lovato liam payne um who
would you like to work with
down the line like in the future what is
your dream collaboration moving forward
um it's so hard to choose i mean it's
like
but for me i've always liked like my
dream collab i guess would be like paul
mccartney just because i've
i've been the beatles fan since i was a
little kid like i just love them and
just being able to do something
like with somebody as iconic as him
would be unreal
um so i guess i guess he would be like
my number one
yeah tanasha what about you do you have
a dream collab oh my dream collab is
andre three thousand
oh very good choice that would be just
so crazy so i'm going to keep saying it
until it happens
yeah have you met him i haven't i need
to
i just want to feel the energy i want to
see the flu i want the whole thing
i've only i've only met him once and it
was years ago and he was in pajamas
and he had a bowl of cereal yes
that sounds like the andre i'm trying to
me a bowl of cereal
in pjs it was in the middle of the day i
was like what in the andre 3000 is this
trevor have you met paul mccartney no
that would be unreal i would like i
don't even know what i would do you like
just dm them
i don't think he does he check dms like
maybe it's worth a shot i should
definitely hit him
have twitter i don't know he's got to
have some i don't know
he's got to hit up all the socials yeah
exactly
uh well guys i love this song it was so
nice to see you
talk to you congratulations i hope
there's more
thank you
you